Laughing so hard that no noise comes out is
actually good for your health.
It reduces your risk of heart disease.
About one in every 4 million lobsters is born
with a rare genetic defect that turns it blue.
And one in every 30 million lobsters is yellow.
The Mimic Octopus doesn't just change colour
it can also mimic the shapes of other sea
creatures like the lionfish and sea snakes.
The left lung is smaller than the right lung
to make room for the heart.
The original surveyors of Mount Everest lied
and added 2 feet to its height to make it
29,002 feet.
Because they didn't think people would believe
them if they said it was really 29,000 feet
high.
Bacteria can get viruses and viruses can also
get viruses.
The Canadian University of Victoria offers
a course in the science of Batman.
The United States, Liberia and Burma are the
only countries in the world that have not
officially adopted the metric system as their
standard of measurement.
Seahorses form monogamous lifetime relationships
and travel in pairs, holding each other's
tails.
A fortunate two percent of the population
have a genetic variation that doesn't cause
any body odour when they sweat.
Ashton Kutcher tried Steve Job's fruitarian
diet when getting into character for the JOBS
movies and ended up in hospital because it
seriously messed up his pancreas levels.
Steve Jobs died of Pancreatic Cancer.
99% of all the species that have ever lived
are now extinct.
The praying mantis has only one ear, which
is located between its legs.
Modern homing pigeons find it easier to follow
motorways and turn left and right at junctions
instead of using their in-built navigational
abilities.
More than one in five Americans believes that
the world will end in their lifetime.
Wars kill more civilians than soldiers: in
a war, the safest place to be is usually in
the army.